When I buy the collection or when I get
the figure it's mainly for...
For peace of mind,
and there's this whole mentality of
"if I don't have a specific figure, I cannot sleep."
My first collection was G.I. Joe comics
when I was 9 years old.
I still remember this
very clearly, I had a really good friend
he had this issue of G.I. Joe I thought
was really good and the cover was Cobra Commander.
The colors really popped and then from
there the love for superheroes grew from
that comic collection.
The tactility of a figure or a statue is
very special right so when you
see a character let's say for example my
favorite character, Nightcrawler,
looking at the image on the page and
holding it is two very different things
based off that feeling or and I decided
that collecting action figures fulfills
a deeper need for that love than
just print.
Hi! My name is Neal, I'm 45 years old.
and welcome to my superhero man cave
Oddly enough, I didn't collect action
figures to begin with.
My first piece was Doctor Doom.
The whole idea of collecting
Doctor Doom was not so much
about the character because I wasn't really that interested in Doctor Doom but the pose,
the sculpting, the whole essence of
how he looked was just incredible.
It called out to me.
I could literally hear the voice inside my head saying, "You have to buy me!"
and at 14 years of age, you don't really have a lot of money.
I could still remember the shop from Siglap Center
and the owner was very nice so when I told the uncle,
"Hey I really want this, is there any way
I can do some sort of like deposit kind
of thing - he's very nice when he says
okay little boy, you can just pay me $50
a month I think after five months you can get it."
so that's how I managed to get Doctor Doom.
I don't really follow the market prices
because when I buy the
collection or when I get the figure
it's mainly for peace of mind and there's this
whole mentality of...
"If I dont have a specific figure, I cannot sleep."
It'll always be in my mind trying to think about
"okay how do I get this?", you know ," where can I go?"
it's always a little nagging doubt
that keeps me awake at night.
Most of it are action figures are from a
six inch scale and most of my figures are
from the DC side are either
Mattel or DC Direct then for Marvel is
either Hasbro or Marvel Select
Currently I have a supplier like a
personal friend of mine,
he is the one going to get all this action
figures so shout out to Mervin Foo that
gets all of my items for me.
It's not so much a collection then it's an obsession.
to me it's almost like a drug.
Every time I get a certain item that has been hard to find,
I feel this whole sense
of accomplishment.
In the past there were certain figures that - because of the way the company distributes it.
there will be rare figures that are so hard to find that even though you searched
all around you cannot find it, and I was
lucky enough that, back then my work
allowed me to travel. Every time I travel
I will visit all the toy stores and find
the figures at Singapore doesn't have.
Currently I have everything I need to have.
For Marvel Legends I have
every single figure produced back when
it was under ToyBiz in the late 90s and
moved over to Hasbro Legends.
I have every single figure,
even the exclusives and the variants.
During that period, some of them will
really hard to get because I think one
of the waves was exclusive to like a
retailer in the U.S. that was really hard to get.
Even within the region you
cannot find it and this is back before the
"internet days", back before Amazon...
that wave would be the Giant Man wave.
You've really got to search high and low to find it,
which eventually I managed to find it.
I had to pay every pretty penny, the prices were at least
three to four times what would have gone at retail.
So the thing about collecting
is how you display them.
Collectors are also hoarders, the only
difference between hoarders and collectors
are that the collectors are
able to display them in a very nice way
and identify where everything lies
specifically.
Most of the items has a
very special emotional connection and
memory attached to it.
If you point out to a specific figure, I can probably
tell you a bit more about where I was,
what I was doing when I purchased it. To
me story is also very important it has
to be correct to that characters story line.
If you know the history of Ghost Rider, he rides
a motorcycle and because of his supernatural abilities,
his motorcycle can go up vertical surfaces.
How I display the Ghost Rider figures are all
on vertical sections.
Spider-man is the easiest because Spider-Man swings from building to building.
Again, if you look at
all the stuff you see all the various
Spider-Mans' swinging from location to
location and I also try not to duplicate
my Spider-Man in terms of the poses so
every Spider-Man has a unique pose
that is identifiable to his action.
Todd McFarlane had a very unique, distinct style whenever he drew Spider-Man's web.
- I don't throw away anything so I still have twisty ties, it grew to a point where it started to get out of hand.
and I realized if I actually joined
all the twisty ties it looked almost
identical to Todd McFarlane's web...
I had a really good friend back then,
he was like a DIY carpenter. He came in, he
suggested hey you know why don't you put it on the ceiling.
you can actually built
like a walkway, catwalks across.
Then I have all these walkways for additional
collection and additional display.
What I've learned is careful planning and
making sure that every figure can stand on
its own so that when the figures are
displayed all by itself
it looks natural. I tend to arrange them
by grouping, again, it's always about the story.
So if we look at this level here...
They're all arranged according to their groups so
like the Superman group, the Batman group
and the Justice League, Justice Society
and the magic users and then so on and so forth.
How much is it worth? About five
years ago I did a rough calculation
everything's worth about $150,000 (Singapore Dollars) all together
One statue is about $300 to $350 and I have about
maybe 400 to 500 pieces and
then one action figure is about let's
see $20 to $30 and I have about two thousand.
Now, I think I wouldn't sell
anything because these are the stuff that I really want.
If there's a fire I
have probably saved myself first.
My rationale is money you can always make,
stuff you can always collect but health and
family is one thing that you can never
replace.
If I go head in and burn myself then I would not be able to enjoy my other collection in the future.
Personally yes
I feel like my life would be duller without the collection.
When I have like a
long day and I come here I sit down look
look at some of the pieces, it helps me to to
relax and gives me peace of mind so that
when I look at a certain range
or a certain grouping, the mind naturally slows down
and any stress or problems that
I'm facing at work or home
sort of is able to go under the
undercurrent and then when I step out of the room,
I have a different frame of mind
and I can approach the challenge in a different way.
Collectors need to have more interaction
with each other because I know a few collectors
out there who we happen to be friends with.
But I'm sure there are other
people out there that have better or
different kind of collections and I'm always
trying to see whether I can meet up with them
because I think we share the same
passion. If you're gonna display them in
this kind of manner and only you see it
I think it's a bit of a shame right?
So for me, anyone that wants to come in
and see, I'm happy to invite them.
I also feel like there are people out there that have the same kind of mind frame.
It'll be nice if we can have a like a
collecting community/gathering where
We can we can sit down and visit each other's home.